así que digamos que tenemos la ecuación
menos 7 x menos 7 x menos 8 y menos 8 y
esto igual a 28 y esta que tenemos aquí
es una ecuación lineal que está escrita
en la forma estándar y lo que quiero que
hagamos en este vídeo es reescribir esta
ecuación en la forma pendiente ordenada
al origen así que eso es recordatorio
estar aquí es la forma estándar la forma
estándar
a andar y lo que queremos es reescribir
esta ecuación en la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen
d
nada al origen origen que por cierto
tiene la forma y es igual a m x + b
james es igual a la pendiente por x más
la coordenada en ye de la intersección y
así que veamos cómo resolvemos este
problema y para esto vamos a necesitar
un poquito de manipulación algebraica y
como siempre te encargo que pausar el
vídeo e intente resolverlo por tu cuenta
antes de que yo lo haga así que bueno lo
que realmente quiero es aislar esta y
del lado izquierdo de la ecuación y para
esto lo que quiero hacer es eliminar
este menos 7x y la mejor forma de
eliminar este menos 7x es sumar 7x así
que de este lado voy a sumar 7x del lado
izquierdo de la ecuación y para mantener
esta igualdad voy a hacer lo mismo de
ambos lados así que sumemos 7x d
ambos lados sumemos 7x de ambos lados y
después con que me quedaremos bueno me
quedaré en el lado izquierdo menos 7 x 7
x se cancelan y me quedaré con menos 8
james así que lo voy a poner aquí menos
8 y james mientras que del lado derecho
me va a quedar 7x más 28 7 x más 28 y
ahora solo quiero está y tenemos aquí
por lo tanto quiero eliminar este
coeficiente de menos 8 y la mejor forma
de hacerlo es dividir ambos lados por
menos 8 así que voy a dividir ambos
lados por menos 8 y que me va a quedar
esto lo voy a dividir entre menos 8 y
esto también lo voy a dividir entre
menos 8 y bueno del lado izquierdo nos
vamos a quedar solo con james es por eso
que dividimos todo entre menos 8
es igual a 7 dividido entre menos 8 es
menos siete octavos menos siete octavos
de equis y después veintiocho dividido
entre menos ocho es lo mismo que menos
siete medios y justo así es como
llegamos a la forma pendiente ordenada
al origen porque escrita de esta manera
inmediatamente no salta que la pendiente
es de menos siete octavos o la pendiente
de la recta que representa todas las
soluciones de esta ecuación lineal o los
pares x james que la satisfacen mientras
que por otro lado la intersección james
si quisiéramos graficar ese punto las
coordenadas serían cero coma menos siete
medios es el valor que nos da esta forma
de aquí y bueno aquí tenemos ya la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen